in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I show a fishing friend all the
tools he'll need to catch a big
performance problem will this be the one
that got away stay tuned to find out so
my friend Carter has built a new website
called bait and stitch which helps
fishing enthusiasts connect with
designers to make custom apparel after a
few weeks in beta Carter asked for some
help he was noticing that his request
latency got significantly slower under
heavy load due to the fact that new
instances took longer times to start now
typically when I hear feedback like this
it means one thing
cold boot performance see when a new app
engine instance is spun up for the first
time it has to execute a bunch of work
that only occurs during initial boot
things like starting the debugger
initializing global variables or
pre-populating some memcache data
performance becomes a concern here
because instances that are typically
created in response to a request that
comes in so if an instance is booting up
the total time to respond to that
request is a function of the normal work
that needed to be done for that response
as well as any startup work that has to
be done as well now to be very very very
clear here cold boot performance isn't
normally a problem app engine startup
time is really fast I mean take a look
at this I charted the cold boot time for
basic hello world application across
various instant types 250 milliseconds
is actually pretty fast for an f2
instance to boot up I mean that's
secondly faster than fetching a
JavaScript file for most CDNs on a 4G
connection which means GAE by itself is
really good at responding to instance
creation time however the users of baton
stitch were noticing performance issues
because of cold boot time which meant
that it was time for Carter and I to sit
down and dig in and figure out what was
going wrong and our first stop was take
a look at vite logging data see out
engine does a really good job of logging
information about each request that it
receives most important of which is how
long it took for the request to be
handled by the service now logged items
which correspond to system events are
often logged in blue start up time is
one of those items so we can click on
the log entry to get more data start up
requests will typically have a header
value of loading requests set to 1
furthermore these log entries are
flagged with some extra information
nation that tells you about the instance
being spun up and how it'll be a little
bit slower than a typical request now
looking at the logs we can see that
there's a group of really fast requests
at the bottom of the set which confirms
exactly what we're expecting the loading
request is actually pretty slow what we
didn't expect however is the batch of
calls in the middle which follow the
loading request those are just as slow
but sadly at this point logging won't
give us any more information so it's
time to switch over to something a
little more powerful and one of the nice
things about App Engine being a platform
as-a-service is that it's got a bunch of
nifty other tools built into it that you
don't have to go generate yourself one
of the more powerful ones is stack
driver tracing see and in addition to
being logged each request that comes
through App Engine standard gets its RPC
call information tracked and listed in
stack driver to find loading requests we
need to dig around a bit they typically
aren't listed directly but they have a
higher response time than normal
requests that come through to confirm
this you can select a trace if the debug
late started command is in the trace
details then it's what you're looking
for this block only executes when a new
instance has been spawned so it's a
clear sign that this was a request that
caused a cold boot to occur now as
mentioned any RPC calls that your app
makes will be logged here and we can see
that this app is touching memcache doing
a fetch and pushing some stuff to task
queues none of those really look like a
performance problem at this point but
what's really interesting here is that
there's about 900 milliseconds before
the socket was created to allow a
connection to the instance this is a
rough indicator of the startup time
taken so app engines boot time isn't the
problem and none of our RPC requests are
the problem but baten stitches loading
time is still about 1.2 seconds to get
more insight we need to profile more of
our code see tracing does a great job of
keeping a tab of what RPC function calls
take but it doesn't track all custom
code that occurs between those calls to
do that we need to leverage the stack
driver trace API that allows us to
insert custom tracing data into our
requests Carter and I were able to write
a small utility class which tracked the
start and end time of various code
segments and returned those results into
a JSON string on demand adding a little
entry exit
up and we quickly had an API to log how
long a block of code takes passing that
data off to the stackdriver API allowed
us to insert custom tracing data for
blocks of code that weren't previously
being logged pretty neat huh
now with the custom tracing setup we now
had a very clear picture of what was
going wrong in the bait and stitch
applications called boot time and it
wasn't pretty but to figure out that
problem we needed to dig in a little
deeper which is a subject for a
different video if you want to learn
more about tracking down performance
problems make sure you check out the
rest of the cloud performance Atlas
videos and don't forget when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts